collègue la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur par oui allez-y allez-y pardon
excusez-moi excusez-moi chers collègues
monsieur delcro vous avez la parole pour
le groupe Union centriste vous avez 5
minutes monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre Mons président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général chers collègues tout
au long de cette première partie le
groupe de l'Union centriste a présenté
des propositions autour d'un CAP clair
réduire le déficit budgétaire par la
mise en œuvre d'une politique fiscale
plus juste visant les très grosses
fortunes et non les classes moyennes
comme je l'ai entendu et nous nous
réjouissons de l'adoption par le Sénat
de plusieurs amendements allant dans ce
sens le renforcement de la contribution
exceptionnelle sur les très haut revenus
elle cible particulièrement les super
dividendes qui échappent à la
progressivité de l'impôt de depuis la
mise en place du pfu en 2018 la réforme
de l'exit taxe qui garantira que les
contribuable contrôlant une société
ayant bénéficié du soutien financier
massif de l'État ne puisse échapper à
l'impôt sur les plus-valu en se
délocalisant seulement 2 années à
l'étranger avant de les céder la
taxation des rachats d'action par les
très grandes entreprises une pratique
qui a explosé ces dernières années il
s'agit de les encourager à investir dans
l'économie réelle
plutôt qu'à faire monter le cours des
actions la suppression de plusieurs
niches fiscales dans un triple objectif
de redressement des finan publi
d'efficacité économique et d'équité
sociale le renforcement du plan de lutte
contre la fraude fiscale ou encore le
remplacement de l'impôt sur la fortune
immobilière par un impôt sur la fortune
improductive pour une taxation plus
juste des actifs financiers
improductif nous avons aussi défendu la
mise en œuvre de politiques publies
utiles par l'adoption de plusieurs
amendements comme par exemple le
maintien du prix àau zéro en zone rurale
pour ne pas pénaliser les primos
accédents souhaités résider à la
campagne ou encore l'augmentation de la
DGF notamment pour rétablir la hausse de
la DSR au niveau de
2023 enfin la réforme des ZRR je ne peux
pas passer sous silence ce sujet si sur
la forme son examen à mon sens trop
précipité a parfois conduit à un peu de
confusion sur le fond et c'est cela qui
compte au fond sur le fond le résultat
est à la hauteur des enjeux grâce à une
convergence quasi totale entre le Sénat
et le gouvernement au seul bénéfice des
territoires ruraux sur cette question à
fort enjeu et à forte portée symbolique
je tiens à remercier particulièrement
d'abord madame la Première ministre
d'avoir inscrit la pérenisation de ce
dispositif à plusieurs reprises menacé
de disparition dans le plan France
ruralité annoncé en juillet dernier
dernier et sa concrétisation dans la loi
de finances pour 2024 sous la forme de
France de France ruralité revitalisation
je veux remercier aussi la ministre en
charge des collectivités territoriales
Dominique fort qui durant plusieurs mois
a joué la carte de la concertation avec
les parlementaires et les associations
d'élus pour rechercher le consensus le
plus large autour de la meilleure
réforme améliorant ainsi la copie
initiale du gouvernement enfin merci à
vous monsieur le ministre présent tout
au long de ce débat pour votre écoute et
votre ouverture sur cette question
importante l'accord conclut avec le
entre le gouvernement et le Sénat c'est
traduit par un vote unanime ou quasi
unanime rassemblant toutes les
sensibilités et tous les territoires
autour d'un projet commun un projet qui
répond aux besoins des territoires
ruraux et un message positif
encourageant adressé au secteur rural et
c'est important alors Monsieur le
Ministre là du coup je m'adresse à vous
après cet accord trouvé grâce à une
réelle concertation après ce vote
unanime au Sénat nous comptons sur le
gouvernement pour que le texte définitif
qui pourrait faire l'objet d'un 493
respecte l'accord trouvé avec la chambre
des territoires voilà un balayage rapide
de notre des rapports de notre groupe
qui au global ça a été rappelé contribue
au redressement des finances publiques
grâce aux économies réalisées il ressort
du Sénat à notre sens un texte solide
qui répond aux enjeux du moment et nous
le voterons je vous remercie merci chers
collègues la parole est maintenant
madame